buy this pay-per-view they're going to  come out to the rocket mortgage field  house  what can you guarantee them on sunday  night  look another show another massive  performance a boxing clinic  you know people know how i'm coming 3-0  3 ko's that's for a reason  i didn't even get warmed up in my last  fight so  this guy's going to go to sleep  and he's going to get turned in to  another meme like i said just like his  best friend  is his little guy ben askren who he was  in the corner of turned him into a meme  ended his career  after sunday no one ever he was sorry  about this guy  no one's ever gonna talk about this guy  ever again he's a speed bump in the road  of the jake paul career  he's a boss  he's a body he is a body that i am using  to add new content to my highlight look  at you a clown  i know they're members of the media